thank you join me in welcoming hi wow
people are standing in the back but
actually being in the back means you can
leave and you won't be noticed this is
the title slide let me make clear that
the work I'm talking about I will
sometimes mistakenly say I when I mean
we the work I'm talking about is work
done by me and Lenore and we're equal
participants in this so then a machine
be conscious here's the so here's what
I'm going to do I'd like to start off by
at least telling you what I think
consciousness is you know different
people have different notions of what's
conscious what consciousness is but for
me what it is it's what you see what you
hear what you feel you know if you have
a stomachache that you're conscious of
that so consciousness is all that and it
includes your dreams and also your inner
speech you talk to yourself amanda says
yes I've asked people who are deaf if
they talk to themselves and and yes they
do they use sign language it's a visual
speech and I suspect that dogs also talk
to themselves but they use some language
called doggish and I don't know what it
is I only recently learned that with
dogs if their tail wags to the left it's
interpreted differently than if it wakes
to the right and
we humans still know their language but
that's that's interesting okay so here
are examples of consciousness so the
example I like is you I don't know if
this happens to you you go to a party
you see somebody who's you name you
should know but you don't remember it
and so you know it's a little
embarrassing but you go around and you
get some wine and and then half an hour
later it pops into your head
Brian that's the name okay so this is an
example where you are consciously asking
for a name and you don't know where that
name comes from but your unconscious is
working on that and that's the reason
that half an hour later that name can
pop into your head it's been working on
this problem so here's where I'm coming
from I will I believe it should be
possible to build a machine that is
conscious and has free will and feels
the torment of pain and the ecstasy of
joy just as much as any human in other
words I come from I my sense is that we
know physics we know we know how things
work it's been a really remarkable thing
and I think that the physics we know is
enough to explain these things not
everybody agrees in fact very few people
agree it's often called the hard
question the easy question is building a
robot that feels pain or feels joy and
the hard part is building a robot that
really the easy part is building one
that simulates feeling pain simulates
feeling joy and the hard part is making
it so it really does feel so that's what
I'm after it's called the hard problem
so the machine is to really experience
qualia like the ache of pain the ecstasy
of joy and not just simulate the
experience and we succeed if appropriate
yeah we succeed how do we tell if we
succeed you can find YouTube videos on
the web of robots that are apparently in
pain they look like they're in pain but
you know that that they're stimulating
it and how do you tell when they really
feel I think we have to build this thing
and I would say that we build it so that
it's not designed in any special way to
feel ecstasy or to but it will it will
it will emerge those feelings of pain
and joy should emerge from the
architecture and not be programmed in
and if by not programming in we can get
those feelings to emerge then I'd say
we're on our way ok so our view of
consciousness consciousness is the
property of all properly organized
systems here and that it's the
architecture not the particular whether
it's made out of transistors or neurons
this is not the point
ok so so let me also explain that
this this this wonderful place has many
excellent neuroscientists I am NOT a
neuroscientist I'm a computer scientist
I'm a theoretical computer scientist and
what what can i as the theoretical
computer scientist possibly hope to do
so I'm going to try to do something
which is what something that long I'm
going to take a lead from Alan Turing
Alan Turing turns out actually did
he designed a computer which he called
the ACE computer and there was a baby
ace computer built but there was a real
computer that he completely designed
down to the resistor values and the
capacitor values everything you might
want to even had a said it cost it would
cost eleven thousand pounds whatever
that was at the time to build it it was
really but besides actually building
that which amazes besides designing that
he also designed a very very simple
computer which we nowadays called the
Turing machine and this very simple
computer you know high school students
can build working examples of the simple
one because it is so very simple and the
the idea was the idea that Turing had
was with this very simple Turing machine
that said he was interested in what can
a computer do and what can it not do and
he needed this very simple model in
order to be able to say what it can do
and what it can't do and to prove that
some things cannot be done you know this
is not possible to write a program for a
computer to decide if another program
will halt in general so it's called the
halting problem and this is work that
came out of Turing so I would like to
try we Lenore and I would like to try to
do the same sort of thing and what we're
going to what we're doing is we're
defining something called the conscious
Turing machine the idea behind this it's
the architecture of this is different
from Turing machine and the intent is
different Turing was interested in
deciding what problems can or cannot be
solved by a computer I'm interested in
how it does consciousness arise so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to talk
about I'm going to show you how the
conscious Turing machine is defined and
then I will try to point out from this
how a robot consciousness could arise
this and in also how feed freedom of the
will could arise from this and also how
the agony and the ecstasy could arise
from this model now again I when I tell
people that I'm doing this and I have
some ideas for how a ganene ecstasy
could arise a lot of people turn around
and that's it they won't have anything
more to do with me because that's crazy
it's interesting how very how they won't
even listen this just so-so but here you
are you're sitting and you're listening
and so I have I have a chance to maybe
do something I do want to make this
point that I'm going to distinguish
human consciousness from robot
consciousness I'm going to be talking
about robot consciousness and every so
often I will point out the resemblance
to human consciousness or you may do
that yourself
but basically it's real about
consciousness I'm interested in we do
believe that the different definitions
and insights for what we call robot
consciousness will shed light on human
consciousness so again the conscious
Turing machine we define here is a at
best a gross simplification of a brain
it has very little of what's in the
brain it's I'm trying to get just enough
to be able to explain consciousness and
ecstasy and agony it's related to a real
brain the way Turing machine is and I'm
not trying to we are not trying to get
an exact model our goal is to understand
consciousness so what follows we
distinguish the consciousness defined in
our model from the consciousness in the
in the brain okay so having said that we
are greatly inspired by cognitive
neuroscientists and philosophers and
psychologists
and these are a few of the names and I'm
going to start with in the upper left
hand corner you see Bernie Bernie bars
he's there because he's alphabetically
the first of these but actually he came
up with a very wonderful model of of the
brain attempt to understand
consciousness it turns out that in 1870
there was a man a Frenchman named eople
politte ten I think I don't speak French
anyway who came up with this notion of a
stage representing what we are conscious
of and the audience representing all the
unconscious processors in our brain so
this this was great and then nothing
much came of it till Bernie bars came
along and he came along just before fMRI
was invented and because of that I
believe this this could start to take
off to take off this whole notion of
consciousness but it's more than that
Bernie bars also gave us a kind of an
idea of what how the brain should be
architected so the earth burning he was
also at Berkeley for quite a while so so
I loved what he what he has done let me
now tell you his his model his it's a
theater analogy and he says that
conscious awareness can be viewed as an
actor on the stage and that and only
that is what you're conscious of but
what's going on on the stage is being
viewed by all the members of the
audience and if you ask what's that
person's name you don't know where which
processor has that information but it's
there somewheres and you hope the
processor that's there seeing that you
want the answer will pop it into your
into your head
there's bars theater and this is the
model that he proposes it's a very nice
model but it doesn't have the details I
want I would like to have a really fully
well-defined model where I could
actually define consciousness here's the
conscious Turing machine it's let me
just say it's more formal but I don't
feel I'm still there they're there there
are bits and pieces I have to finish we
have to finish with but we have hopes
that we're getting there so you
understand what I'm trying to do here
I'm going to try to give you this model
and the point of the model is that it's
the architecture of this model that I
think is what accounts for our current
our consciousness it's an architecture
that's different from the architecture
that's currently used for any of our
computers it's quite different so here's
the model starting off there's this
short-term memory it's called off in a
working memory a lot of people there you
sit on the floor over here anyway so
there's a working memory
I call it short-term memory but it's
probably the psychologists call it
working memory that's what we're
conscious of we are to some extent
conscious of the input I had here before
a picture of a house you remember it
described it for me
house turned upside down good you have
any more information you can add to that
yes there was a little doghouse upside
down there oh that's good yes open
dumpster is that toboggan and bicycle go
bicycle
did you see did you all see it it's
amazing but I think in this model what
we have stored is not that picture we
just don't have enough in our head to be
able to store that what we have is
essentially a description of what's
there some short description it can be
explained in English but of course in
our brain it would be stored and
brainish so here's the external input
there is the upside down house this by
the way is a real house it's in Moscow
it's a quite a nice for tourist
attraction does anybody see the stairs
going up to the front door and and
everything is the dog is up there it's
upside down everything inside is glued
to the ceiling and it's a really a fun
house to visit what I'm gonna talk about
is what's going on in short term memory
let me mention I don't do you remember
perhaps you seeing Yoda lifting a
spaceship and wondering especially when
you're a kid can I do that can I now you
try and it's really kind of you know but
we that's how we learned what we are
versus what everything else is we we
know that we can move our hand but can't
move Amanda's hand that's just won't
move for me and you know babies you can
sort of see them when they're learning
that wow I can do this and discover oh I
can do the other one too and that's how
you learn who and
you are so here's you I'm putting you
down as Yoda but you know I'm trying to
imagine lifting that rock and what you
do is you actually try to lift but
whether or not you're actually able to
do that well the way you tell is really
by by looking you have no idea you give
the instructions lift the rock but
whether or not you succeed or you have
to actually look to be able to see okay
so in an example of that sort of thing
is can you can you wiggle your ears but
you know you can try and then you won't
know until you look in the mirror and
see if you succeeded so I have to get to
this so here's short-term memory on top
and the unconscious audience down at the
bottom just a point is that everything
here is dynamically changing especially
you know that I have there that external
world is dynamically changing but so are
all these memories and these processors
okay this slide and then the next few
slides are really the meat of this model
and in this model we have a tree
representing the fact that whatever is
in short-term memory is broadcast to all
of the unconscious processors there are
huge number of unconscious processors I
think of every neuron each one of our 10
to the 11th neurons as being an
unconscious processor so there's a huge
number of unconscious processors I'll
just say 10 to the 11th
but remember I'm interested in robot
consciousness I don't really know I just
so anyway so there is this tree and
whatever's up there is broadcast down to
the bottom I represent this as a binary
tree but it could be more but for the
simple model I want a binary tree and
that's okay because you can get down and
very very quickly from a single node at
the top to 10 to the 11th neurons at the
bottom okay so this this will do for
what we do want and this is fast
broadcast from up there down to what's
below and then there's the question of
how does the information get back up to
the stage the there's a processor there
you know there is a processor that's
concerned with faces it's wonderful that
there's a processor in our brain that's
concerned to the faces you you know
nowadays you can find these cameras that
will put blocks around all of the faces
and do lots of boxes here it's wonderful
well there's a processor that does that
and they're also processor that will
name the faces that it knows this goes
on and a part of our brain called the
fusiform face area but the important
thing is there are many different
processors and their information goes up
and they have to this information goes
up but it's got to go up more slowly
because which information will go up one
one processor has some information and
another processor has some other
information how how do they decide what
actually gets up there what the
short-term memory is tiny I'll explain
why the model requires it to be tiny
even though we can have really big
short-term memories you'll see why it
has to be tiny
I mean basically the idea is that I want
all of the processors down here concept
paying attention to what's on the stage
not just one processor paying attention
to this and another processor paying
attention to that I want them all paying
attention to exactly the same thing and
the way you can get that is by making
that short-term memory that we are
conscious of small here's how
information goes up so what what what we
have here is there are these processors
and there are triples associated with
each processor I'm representing them as
for example pain - five it really should
be pain then
leg - five there's the pain or the
address of the processor that feels the
pain
there is the location or whatever is
important for the stage is next to
that's a pain maybe left knee and then a
weight of some sort and that weight
comes about because you know you have
these nociceptors these these nerve
fibers that send information up and
they're only a few fibers fire fire
there's not too much if a lot of fibers
fire and there there's a higher
frequency of firing than the weight
associated with the pain will grow and
the same thing is true for all of these
processors you can build in what the
weight should be depending on how these
nerves what the nerves do the same thing
is true for joy I don't know if anything
like neuro and nerves for joy but there
is in the brain itself their selves are
very much concerned with with stuff like
joy and more and more of those fire then
you get a higher weight for joy the way
the stuff goes up just like this pain -
five joy plus three they get together
which one is going to go up well pain
has the greater magnitude wait see the
forget that sign the five is bigger than
the three so pain will go up and it goes
up but with a weight equal to the sum
minus five plus three is minus two now
this is how the model is working I'm not
saying that that's what's going on in
the brain but you could ask yourself
according to this G is it true that if
you have very strong pain and very great
pleasure that the two will subtract that
the pain and the pleasure can subtract
and so there are questions like this
which one could ask about the real brain
and you know I have I think this is
reasonable you go to a dentist have you
ever had laughing gas
a wonderful wonderful experience and the
dentist is told you you you give enough
laughing gas so they don't feel the pain
but not more not more it's sort of like
the laughing gas is bringing pleasure to
the point where it offsets the pain and
if you go too far then you get manic and
you don't want that and when you're
supposed to be work he's supposed to be
working on the tooth so and so here you
see pain fear which goes up which goes
up here because it's got a greater
magnitude and what does and what does it
go up with negative seven good that's
and Angele Angele okay there it is here
and minus seven thank you and so so it
goes up so these are things that could
be tested actually if you want to do but
this is what the model is requiring and
the extent to which it's true I don't
know let me also add to this model some
complications that I don't really like
but I need to because there are some
processors that need to have be able to
see what the external input looks like
and you can have lines from the external
input going to really to all processors
it's a lot of lines but at least to the
processors that need them and also lines
going up to the external output and this
is the summary slide this is the model
right here one of the questions that I'm
sometimes asked is what about
connections between individual
processors shouldn't they be there but
it turns out if they're 10 to the 11th
processors down here and if there were
all pairs of connections that would be
1/10 of all pairs were connected 10 to
the 22nd that's close to abogados
numbers that's a big number
it's just you're not going to have that
in the brain so you can't have all that
but so I'm not putting any of it I'm not
having those although one could do the
following you could say that if face
a face processor ask if the if the face
and the fear talk to each other at some
point
maybe you ask what the face name is and
something comes up from fear this is
something to be afraid of then maybe the
face and fear talk to each other I could
imagine fibers growing between the two
that was a lot more direct but in this
model if they're going to talk to each
other the information has to go up it's
got to come back down okay so that's yes
another important point ears no central
executive so Bernie bars model has a
central executive that sort of runs the
show and Turing machine has a central
executive a finite-state part of the
machine which runs the show here there's
no central executive but that's only
because what that that the stuff that
the central executive does could be done
by one of these processors down here oh
I don't have a central executive you
even though this might think it's
necessary you don't need it some other
details already said each other
yeah I mentioned each unconscious
processor has a unique fixed address
it's not necessarily an address hook in
the computer but there's a way of
locating it there is a way to locate
each particular processor and their this
processor that's going up maybe has to
do with fear this processor has with it
some associated information that's a
tiger you don't want to get too close
and there's a weight associated with
them and so that what I showed is pairs
or really triples which are the address
the information and the weight and the
weight is a measure of the importance
assigned to getting that information up
to the stage the information like look
for faces
or the request what's that face name
some more details however weights
assigned to various processors that I've
talked I've mentioned already that it's
how many pain or nerves are firing and
how what frequency therefore iron that
determines the weight there's a context
process there's a processor there that's
concerned just with where how'd you get
to be here and what are you doing here
maybe wondering that yourself so anyway
so context processor and that's
available also or to go up as needed it
couldn't so ok oh yeah this one's cute a
task that has been put off you do you
ever feel that that task that you put
off starts to nag you after a while so
I'm pretty sure that the weight of that
task grows as a function of its
importance and the length of time it's
been put off ok so your details I've
already talked to you about how these
this information moves up and the weight
so I've talked about that more details
in a lot of details and still not enough
let's see what's this one the content
yeah this is the fact that what the the
size of the short-term memory very very
small it's something called george
miller's lords from way back 1955 george
miller said you can have at most seven
plus or minus two chunks in
consciousness
he didn't say what a chunk was gave
examples he said it could be a digit it
could be a letter could be a word could
even be a poem that you've memorized so
i'll tell you the definition of a chunk
at least in this model the definition of
a chunk is it's that it's a triple it's
the it's the address and the information
it's really that pair it's the address
the chunk is that location the processor
that that you're looking at and the
information is carrying is bringing you
the the name of the face and in humans
that there's a combat cop said to seven
plus or minus two so I already mentioned
why you want a small number
let's keep on going so this is just I'm
repeating myself the chunk is an address
information pair a particular chunk that
is often on stages the pair address of
processor supplying context and the
information associated with it another
chunk on stage may focus on a particular
task such as driving a car another chunk
might be concerned with texting you know
how what a bad idea that is there's not
enough space to have a lot of room there
okay so I'll give you an example of how
this sort of thing works this is have
you read Oliver Sacks he's uh oh you you
want you said no but you really should
the wonderful read he's a physician and
he wrote these books and he
unfortunately just recently died but
each one of his books gives you an
example of how the stuff is working
beautiful and he meant it describes he
liked hiking he describes going to Swiss
Alps and hiking up in the Swiss Alps and
he says nice
he saw this field he saw sign sign said
beware the bull looked no bull he kept
on going and he went over a ridge and he
saw the bull and he saw the bull
starting to rise on its haunches and
this scared the living daylights out of
him and he turned around and ran as fast
as he could out of that field and he
didn't stop till he got out and he
noticed that he had damaged he had
damaged his leg he actually had torn
ligament which by the way very it kept
him in the hospital for more than a
month afterwards because it was really
bad there but he had not noticed that
the ligament was torn until he got out
of that field and so the idea here is
that you can imagine that
this wrong there is a processor there
that's concerned with fear in our brain
it's the amygdala but it doesn't that
doesn't matter it's the the point is
that there is a processor that
concentrates on fear and there's
possible responses to fear one of them
is fight and the other is flight
there's also freeze like flight freeze I
okay so in this particular case in his
particular case flight one out it took
over and it got up to the stage turn run
and it got up there and it didn't it
took off did not allow any other
processor up on the stage only when that
fear got reduced did the pain actually
manage to come up
that'll be an example
not just Turing machine yeah so the
conscious so okay so this this this
thing is saying that there's an
architecture and dynamics involved here
the architecture is this very tiny
short-term memory that I've talked to
you about this enormous long-term memory
and then the contents of the short-term
memory are being steadily broadcast and
the processors the long-term memory
processors negotiate amongst themselves
to decide what gets up there so that's
that's the architecture I'm talking
about David that's what's not been built
okay so content to the short-term memory
and we're going to suggest that this
we're going to give you a definition
well what you've just seen is most of
the definition of the conscious Turing
machine there's some details left out
but that's the definition and now I want
to say we theoretical computer
scientists define consciousness what the
definition consciousness is what's up in
that short-term memory that's it that's
the definition now this will seem very
very strange to you leave just defining
but is it really I mean is that what's
conscious but in fact that's what we
theoretical computer scientists do we do
things like give a definition to
something and then later by proving
theorems and showing the consequences
maybe you'll agree that that's a good
definition maybe you'll disagree and
actually improve well so I I'm telling
you that consciousness in this model at
least is just what's in that short term
memory and but we suggest why this
definition is reasonable why is that a
reasonable definition of consciousness
of course every single processor in your
brain is aware of what's going on there
that is what you are conscious of that
is what you see feel hear every single
processor is aware of that
okay which long-term okay so now here
are a few things I want to be able to
get to the agony in the ecstasy so I
don't know how much of this I'm going to
be able to get to there are a few things
that my definition of our definition of
consciousness requires inner speech
because you do all speak to yourself and
by inner speech I think you know my dog
has inner doggish he is definitely
speaking to himself in some language and
that's how they can get so by in the
speech I mean something for it could be
inner vision inner odor I don't know
what it is but there's some way to do
planning there is self awareness self
awareness because we have up on that
stage a model of ourselves
it's that model which you know like Yoda
we try Yui we try to lift that rock
there's a model of ourselves for doing
that and then there is motivation it's
desire plus energy you need to be
motivated you need to have motivation
for something by the way so all of these
can be explained in more detail I love
the one for motivation let's see if I
can I want to do something I got these
hidden slides here so I want to I want
to show you something interesting what
happens when you don't have motivation
entertainment okay
here's here's something that they're
interesting disorder that some people
have it's called left Hemi spatial
neglect this is somebody who's left Hemi
spatial neglect they they are simply
unconscious of what's going on they can
see what's going on in the West they
know about it but there's not
consciously aware of it so if you ask
them to draw a pic the pictures on the
left that clock you see how the picture
gets drawn the house the flower this is
a patient with left side neglect they
are not a wuss funny they're not really
aware of the fact that they're
neglecting anything you put food in
front of them food and they eat just
what's on the right-half side of the
plate and they've still hungry it does
not a they don't turn you you can turn
around the plate and then they'll eat
what's what's left but what's going on
here how come they didn't turn it around
themselves because they are unconscious
of it it's simply they are not conscious
they are not motivated to look at that
okay here are some so those are the
three things I require in my definition
of consciousness here are a bunch of
things that at least in human human
there are people who don't have this
stuff and they're fully conscious there
are people who cannot create new
memories there was this wonderful person
hm whom we now know as Henry mOLAISON
who because word operation was unable to
create new memories he had all his old
memories but like no new memories every
dot got created he was conscious
so you see declarative memory creation
is their language for outer speech well
there are people who don't
speaks but they are conscious so I put
it here in red because that's not a
requirement for consciousness face
recognition there are people who simply
cannot recognize they see faces but they
can't recognize their daughter their son
their wife they can't recognize
themselves in the mirror anything when
the fusiform face area goes you can lose
the ability to recognize yourself so
each of these things are things wherein
there is somebody who doesn't feel that
there's this woman yet
s SM who is totally fearless her
amygdala has calcified she's not afraid
of anything - kids - let's keep on going
I want to explain a few things here
freewill emotions such as pain and joy
motivation I've told I'm just going to
go directly to pain you know if you want
to you can ask me later I mean the
explanation for freewill is simple and
beautiful you have free will you know
there's this problem about freewill how
can we have freewill
Samuel Johnson said it was a beautiful
statement he said all science is against
the freedom of the will he lived around
the time of Newton he knew that from
Newton's F equals MA all science is
against the freedom of the will
everything is determined all experience
is for it what a wonderful paradox and
so this can be explained here in this
model that say you're playing or you
want to play chess you have to make a
move it's your turn you you must make a
move and you you you know that you can
either move this piece over here or this
piece over there and you don't know
which what you're going to do until
you've sort of done some computation as
much as you can to try to figure out
which is the better move and until you
figure that out you
have you are free to choose what you you
will do any way that can be turned into
an explanation of free will I don't want
to get into it so there's lots about
free will this is what I want to get to
the question how to engineer a machine
so it really feels emotions oh you know
I could how do I get back to
[Music]
thank you appreciate these whole brains
are very slow okay next question how to
engineer a machine so it really feels
not just simulates emotions this is the
thing that most that some people many
people say yeah well it's impossible you
cannot answer that forget it and that's
what I am wanting to answer now I'm not
don't it's going to be hard for me to
convince you I in order to convince you
I need you to accept first of all that
consciousness has a physical explanation
you don't believe that then you might as
well go because there's nothing I say
will help I'm saying it does have a
physical I need you to accept that it
has a physical explanation and I'm
saying that something like the conscious
Turing machine is a credible model for
consciousness I need you to accept that
for the moment you can change your mind
after you go but if you accept it for
now then I'll be able to tell you they
give you some ideas how this this is
done so how the conscious Turing machine
CTM generates consciousness that I still
have to explain here's a point about the
fact that you know many explanations
involve different chemicals and you know
I'm obviously not going to be happy with
that because knowing the name of a
chemical doesn't necessarily tell you
how that experience gets created
especially not in a robot and I want
this to explain robot consciousness and
the robot probably won't have these
chemicals so you know Lenora would like
me to start with an explanation of how
the brain engineers joy pleasure she
does not like that I started with pain
but it turns out the pain is somewhat
easier to explain and then I do often
get the question why would you why would
you engineer a machine to feel pain
indeed wine so one answer any anybody
answer why yes you want it to be yes
machines are expensive you want them
that they care themselves
knowledge knowledge but part of
it's good that's good
so yes not very good why would you
engineer machine to be open you know if
you understand how pain is generated
there's also a possibility of
engineering it to feel pain when it
injures you and that's one of the things
that I'm especially interested in to
make it I mean right now we have mirror
neurons which help us to feel other
people's pain but we could make it so it
really feels the pain when it injures
you so there's reason to at least
understand pain so let me explain to you
the problem I'm gonna be sticking now to
pain rather than pleasure or other
possibilities pain so to explain I want
to explain the problem of simulating
versus experiencing pain and the one way
to understand this is the the disorder
called pain assam boliya you can look up
a stim boliya it's very interesting but
it has to have pain in front pain as in
boliya people with pain Assam boliya
know about their pain you can you can
cut them they know they're being cut you
can pinch them they know how hard you're
pinching them where you're pinching them
if there's a something hot or cold they
know how hot or how cold it is they know
they can explain it all in vivid detail
but they don't suffer in fact they often
giggle yeah there I see you can find on
YouTube this woman who's being pinched
and pulled and everything and she's
laughing it's they they they can do this
on even with very when they're very
great pain the would you like that
you're saying no good that you you
should be saying no the kids that are
born with this some kids are born with
paint a symbol yo they rarely live past
the age of three I did see one kid that
lived to age five and I've heard it
continues to live now because after four
an age they understand English that can
be told they'll understand this kid
beautiful child when she was born
but before age three they had to remove
all her teeth she was biting her lips
and her tongue then and and then she did
learn that she should watch out but she
was playing ball and her foot must have
gone into a hole or something that she
broke her leg and she knew that she had
broken her leg because she feel feels it
but doesn't suffer and she knew she'd
been told she should stop but she was
having fun so now when you see her you
see one leg is shorter than the other
these are the problems that come up pain
as in boliya the robots that we build
nowadays are like pain a symbolic people
they can simulate but they don't yet
feel and it's that kind of feeling that
I want to explain so I'm going to start
with extreme pain the worst possible
kind of pain make so how does the body
engineer the feeling of extreme pain
make the machine so I sort of many ways
to try to do this and I've been unhappy
with them here the idea is make the
machine unable to do anything except to
concentrate on the pain pain when it
gets up into your conscious mind of its
pain does not allow anything else up
there you are forced to think about it
all attention on the pain take away free
choice under severe pain you can't do
anything else any processor that tries
getting on stage gets immediately pushed
back by the pain
let me mention I've said there are some
things that I don't buy suggestions that
don't work as attested to by a Symbolics
make the reactions to pain automatic
like the finger pulling away from the
flame or generate sweat and increase the
heart rate or given a heavy or dangerous
load make the muscles vibrate you know
and the really terrible pain you can get
nauseous you can vomit these sorts of
things do occur can occur but they're
not what's causing they are not what's
causing the pain but they're still the
question is loss of control enough does
the machine really feel real pain when
it loses free will and is forced to pay
attention to pain partial answer think
of the loss of control suffered when
someone screams relentlessly into your
ear but this is still not enough oh
let's take a look at a special case how
does the body engineer the instant shock
of pain and the explanation for that is
that that shock is because every single
processor is being interrupted there is
this thing called an interrupt whatever
that processor is doing it is forced to
stop and to pay attention elsewhere when
a ligament is torn the shock of pain is
instantaneous how does that excruciating
pain come about and we suggest a severe
pain interrupt so it takes place on
stage the interrupt travels down the
tree to all unconscious processors
forcing each and every processor to
attend on the spot to the interrupt and
this okay so we proposed the sudden
interrupt of all processing systems
registers as shock
do you buy that as the explanation for
pain I can tell you this under
conditions that produce great pain a
symbolics can still think while normals
cannot you are normal
under extreme pain you just can't think
it's actually a bad design when you
probably really should be thinking
because you want to get away from that
you cannot you simply cannot a symbolic
scan wonderful to see you know the great
pain but they can okay bad design okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna stop with that
any questions yes I do think the biggest
computers the question is are the
biggest computer is big enough the titan
supercomputer has 1.7 times 10 to the 15
transistors and that's roughly what the
number of synapses in our brain it's a
little more than the number of synapses
we have like one point three times ten
to the 15th I think that I think the
answer that they're I think that there's
enough when you're thinking doesn't
follow from that that the more
intelligent the person is the less free
will it has because the more food we can
make a decision you know the fact is
that there are some things I can chess
where in many things where it takes a
certain amount of time to do that
computation no matter how smart you are
even the very best machines they cannot
create make instant decisions just as we
know there are some things some
functions that a machine can compute
that can't a machine can't compute we
know there are some functions that a
machine cannot compute quickly that's a
very interesting point thank you yeah I
have to think about that does it mean
that they have less free will or just
their clock is faster yes information
flows down fast
back up slow what's the reason for the
fast and slow
fast down because the information just
is being split out and sent to
everything there's no decisions having
to be made where it's on the way back
fear and pain collide and one of them
gets to go up so a decision has to be
made not a big one but it has to be made
and all the way up and that takes time
no there there's this question I would
like to see one built and there's this
question of how we will know that we
succeeded that we have actually built a
conscious machine it's because we didn't
build in it that it should scream when
it feels pain but it screams when it
feels pain
without like you can live without the
people's faces but then people who can't
feel pain are also conscious yes and
it's one of the things on that list of
not necessary it's a good point
well I because I even though I don't
consider them necessary for
consciousness I want to understand how
this hard problem is solved I want to
understand how the the agony of pain
comes around you're right it's sort of
further down yes I didn't understand
that are you asking why we might want to
build such a machine
well if you know one of the problems
that we have with our current machines
is that there's a machine that plays go
and it plays really good go and there's
a machine that plays chess and they're
machines to do lots of individual things
but one of the problems has been how do
you get a machine that can do everything
and one of the motivations is to come up
with it to come up with this
architecture is because now a lot of
that doesn't have to be built in to be
able to come up with it it's a good
question don't you see that this is all
just being done now because we're not
going to build into it I mean this is we
are not built building it to tune scream
when they feel pain and when they sense
pain it just that would come about
because for some other reason we want
these feelings to emerge from this
general architecture without the
specifics being built in I think yes let
me take this one last question with it
why are you really testing human
situation
though I don't expect the pain the robot
to feel pain from a flame if it's the
pain look there will be other things you
know that will that should cause it pain
there are others I don't I'm not trying
to make this robot respond the way we do
I'm trying to make it respond the way
this entity should should respond thank
you very much
[Applause]